I'm Mario Cantone and I identify as a 25
year old homosexual
[Laughter]
that's your intro to the world this
summer all right I'm mark Anton I
identify as a gay male
that's so weird to say I just think one
finds me how do you identify as your
husband darling my name is Jerry Dixon
I'm Mario Cantone impossible I'm Kristen
Beck I'm a transgender American
my name is Billy Porter and I identify
as an african-american queer man I'm
Sharon Bishop Baldwin I'm a lesbian this
is my wife Mary Bishop Baldwin my name
is Gia
I'm 15 years old I'm transgender my name
is Ryan O'Callahan and identify as a gay
man I have two boys one of which is gay
we stood with our son at the Oklahoma
City Pride Parade and I became an
accidental activist for the lgbtq+
community I came out of the womb with
them with the umbilical cord over my
shoulder and a microphone at the end
singing at Judy Garland I knew right
away because pretty terrific yeah my boy
crazy boy crazy I knew I was gay as soon
as I hit puberty I was so deeply
closeted that I was blind to life and
what was going on around me I came out
when I was 29 years old right when my
NFL career was coming to an end
always me there's something different
about me I always played with girls toys
and I didn't really know what I was I
was so nervous to come out but as soon
as I did I received so much support and
I've been able to be an advocate in my
life I'm just a normal teenager and
being transgender it's just one part of
me the process of coming out has been a
continual process over the decades of my
adult life I came out to my mother three
times finally by the time I was 28 she
got it she wasn't happy with it I
retired from the Navy SEALs in 2011 and
I knew I had to start living my aunt
your life and I find my own happiness
and so that's when I started being a
transgender American is a very tough
life
we're discriminated against were killed
in the streets I was frozen in this idea
that I had to choose between my child
and my faith I no longer believe that
homosexuality is a sin I believe that is
a gift by God I now pronounce Mary and
Sharon should be lawfully now we have
been thanked by literally thousands of
people for filing a lawsuit and for
winning marriage equality in Oklahoma
but at the base of that it was a selfish
act we wanted to get married
Pride Month is a chance for everyone
just to have a little more freedom and
to just show off a little bit we're just
like you we're citizens we're Americans
were people who human beings
[Music]
I'm proud because I've been able to
successfully live my life as a openly
gay man ten years ago I never thought
that that would be possible I'm proud
because I have nothing to be ashamed of
I am Who I am I'm proud that we've had a
role in helping change the world and
improve the lives of LGBTQ Americans I
am proud because I can share my positive
story and I feel like celebrating who I
really am has made me so much happier
with myself I'm a better person because
my child is gay I came out at 13 years
old in 1973 in a suburb of Boston and I
feel so proud about that I'm proud that
we live in a time where there are
possibilities because I really did not
think that getting legally married to
you was a possibility at all as an out
proud gay Christian african-american man
I'm probably that we're better together
we're stronger together love always wins
the month is about reminding the world
that we are here we've always been here
we will continue to be here we're never
going anywhere so get used to it
you